If you think back to
the diagonalization of Turing machines.
You'll notice that we hardly
refer to the properties of Turing
machines at all.
In fact, except at the end,
we might as well have been talking
about a different model of computation,
say, the doomaflitchy.
Perhaps, unlike Turing machines,
doomaflitchies halt on every
input,these models exist.
A model that allowed one step for
each input symbol would
satisfy this requirement.
How do we resolve the paradox then?
Can't we just build the dumaflache
that takes the description of
a dumaflache as input and
then runs it on itself?
It has to halt so
we can reject if it accepts, and
accept if it rejects,
achieving the needed inversion.
What's the problem?
Take a minute to think about it.